this guy called evans he posted today
it's his little son's birthday it's his
son's birthday
so he's there having a cake and i just
saw him post this he posted
one of the most stressful things in life
finances
is very tiny we sleep on this single bed
and i'm really
sick and tired of it that's what he
posted he posted this
like 20 minutes ago so what i'm gonna do
i'm literally gonna message him right
now i'm gonna get his address
i'm gonna drive to his house i'm gonna
sleep on his couch
i'm gonna live with him and his family
for a week so it looks like it might be
a bit tricky this week
so there's zero chance i'll be able to
sleep in the shed and see what happens
and i reckon he's gonna become
financially free
oh my goodness let me get this guy's
address right now
this is my lunch and breakfast i think
that one's going to work
sorry no problem at all i only charge
the english people
sheesh these are kind of things like
what through most people want a one bed
or maybe a two bed
in bedroom already licensed for 15
people i don't think this is a goer
my name's samuel leeds i failed in
school and started with
nothing 10 years later i'm a
multi-millionaire property investor
and now leaving my family in
buckinghamshire to live with evans
here we go
oh well dude
evans lives in london and says he needs
my help as he only has
23 pounds to his hair hey
got his address i'm on my way to his
house right now
i'm 19 minutes away 19 minutes
i'm actually feeling really nervous
right now because
i don't know how this is gonna go and if
i get there
i mean he knows i'm coming he knows i'm
coming but what's he thinking
what's his family thinking what's gonna
happen when i get there
man this is crazy but if this goes to
plan
right now the guy's broke he's got no
money if this goes to plan
in seven days time he will never have to
worry
about money ever again hey
oh man let's see what happens let's see
what happens
hey hey you're right yeah have i got the
right house is it evidence
oh amazing yeah isn't that a coroner
getting into
okay cool
this feels a bit awkward where is evans
it's like he's hiding
oh evans hey hey
what's happening evans how you doing
buddy
good to see you bro how you doing i'm
awesome you guys keep doing well
cool it's the financial freedom
challenge
in regards to the sleeping um
we kind of have to convince ellen's um
ellen's parents a little bit
okay yeah that's no problem
my job is to come around and help
somebody become financially free not to
persuade parents
samuel's here and we've gotta figure out
how he can stay mom and dad aren't too
keen on it
um i mean it's not our house my parents
house we're so excited we're buzzing
stitchy a dream come true
but with like how everything is at the
moment with kobe restrictions
obviously they know how much it means to
us but
turns out this isn't evan's house this
is evan's girlfriend's parents house
evans doesn't have a house
how can i come to someone's house to
help them become financially free when
they don't have a house my goodness
it's very tiny we sleep on this single
bed
this is obviously our goal is to move
into our own place
this is obviously one of my goals to you
know to public speak
in front of hundreds of people uh
this is obviously me learning to speak
spanish
this is obviously you know us getting
married and our kids
i already have one jaden they think they
get another one going
and um yeah the dream holidays and stuff
basically
um i just i just see what the situation
is very small house as you can see there
living arrangements
there is no other bed now jayden's not
here because when his son's here jaden
gets the bed and they both are on the
floor
mattress yeah it's in a difficult
position
i'm just wondering whether we could
install you in the shade so not only
would so instead of being on the floor
you'd be in a shed and when they say
shed it's it's a nice wooden it's not
nothing it's not a garden
i don't mind sleeping in the shed this
is looking like this is going to be my
new home potentially for the week
oh this isn't bad you know we'll
obviously tidy up and make it
comfortable for you
um sorry because we didn't know you were
you were coming so we haven't actually
prepared it as yet that's great i'm
totally happy to stay here
you wouldn't have a bathroom there yeah
yeah that's fine i'm i am honestly
absolutely delighted with it with with
the office shed
so um did you say you needed to check
with
check it check in with um with the other
two children at the moment because
obviously it's a slightly unorthodox
arrangement but i
i think it works and i thought yeah do
you reckon that they'll be okay with it
um i'm not sure let's let's go and find
out
so currently now we're just waiting on
your girlfriend's
sister and mom and brother
and brother to agree that i'm okay in
the shed
yeah okay cool i mean you think they'll
be okay
uh yeah um yeah i think it'll be okay
you don't look convinced i mean they
have to man this means everything
so um so yeah i'm an optimist they'll be
okay okay
i'm so sorry but what i didn't factory
my daughter she is super sensitive
about these kind of issues um at the
moment
so it looks like it might be a bit
tricky this week i'm
really sorry much as we'd love for you
to stay in our shades and i'm sure you'd
be great in the health scares for our
kids
yeah okay now i understand
i understand so there's zero chance i'll
be able to sleep in the shed
it looks that way yeah if it was up to
me then of course we would have samuel
to stay but it's not my
house it's my parents so i'm happy to do
the financial freedom challenge
i'm happy to move into your house maybe
to move into your shed
but why why why didn't why didn't you
why didn't you tell
people that i was actually coming and if
i told my friend they would just
completely shut me down and they
wouldn't even let you into the door so
if i if i get you in the door
you know together we're going to
convince them um so obviously my humble
apologies
that didn't work at all did that and
this is the reason why
you know i want to do this challenge you
know i'm 30 years old i've got lovely
misses i've been selling the dreams for
two years
i feel like now is the time you know for
me to obviously really do something and
get my own place
um you see this is my frustration um
they i mean they're lovely their parents
i love it they give me everything but
you know i just need my own privacy i
need to do my own stuff i need to be a
man i mean i go a kid
you know my kid comes around i sleep on
the floor so i mean i'm i'm really sick
and tired of this i mean i do apologize
for obviously you know not letting you
know the miscommunication but
you know is there any way is there
anything that we can obviously do to
make this happen
yeah okay to be honest most most of the
week we won't even be at home
we're going to be viewing houses and out
on the road but we just need it at the
base it's okay
yeah yeah fine thank you so much amanda
thank you
all right thank you sweet i'll see you
in a bit bye all right
financial freedom challenge at my house
[Applause]
everything you need yep i
this was me when i got to his house and
i wasn't allowed in
i was telling don't waste my time really
really really wanna
you know really at the end of the week
you know give her something back for
everything that she's done for me like
literally
this girl has been there when i was
nothing but overweight lost a lot of bit
of hair
literally had no money like nothing you
know um
you know so i definitely owe a big time
i just really want to give her something
back
i'm just really frustrated as we really
need that one place yeah i guess i'm
gonna unpack
and you've now packed let's go brother
i can get used to this wow
man i'm just so grateful so excited you
guys won't believe what just happened to
me
i'm at sonia tell me at least his house
and uh he's giving me
apparently this is a room but this is
like a mansion it's called
ensuite in there ah
absolutely amazing absolutely pumped
um they didn't start off great um you
you meant to come to my house
unfortunately um it kind of you know it
kind of got thrown out
what's the plan become financially free
okay
and how uh how we're gonna do it
uh i mean that's kind of like why why
are you here
okay in order to determine where we need
to get you we need to determine where
you are right now
so how much money do you have right now
in the bank
right this second now in my four counts
um about 23 pound
i'm completely skinned so i'm not gonna
lie to you i haven't got nothing okay
so you've got 23 pound in your bank
you're skint
you're living with your girlfriend's
parents
you haven't got a job
your only income source is one rent to
rent that you picked up a couple months
ago
from watching some of my training videos
yeah how much you getting off that
750 750 yeah so currently your monthly
income is 750 pounds yeah
what are you doing with that money i'm
just using that to
we have to pay for ellen's room where we
are 450.
i've been living in ellen in that room
for two years she's
giving me everything and i think it's
time for me to pay her back i think
i've been selling dreams for too long so
how much would it cost for you to move
out
i'm in a room in illinois it's probably
like you know 750 to 800 pounds
um 750 to 800 japan a month yeah do you
want to live in a room though
do you want to go from you're living in
a room at the moment like
what's the dream bro where do you where
do you want to live
i mean ideally i really want to live
uh in london a very nice view in a nice
apartment
okay um you know too big what's that
gonna cost like two grand
yeah about two to three grand really
okay so that's the dream
and to then have some extra money as
well to actually live
okay so you need three to four grand a
month
right now in order to be living in a
nice apartment in
london with your girlfriend ellen
so why don't we just do that this week i
mean why haven't you already got some
more instruments why did you only get
one renting right so this is the thing i
mean that was my plan all along you know
i plan to get
a few more but it cost me a lot of money
that i haven't got how much did that
first rent costume um i wanted to give
about 7000 pounds
okay so you put everything into that
like every single penny i haven't got
nothing left to be honest
the second hurdle that i had was
referencing i couldn't get referencing
how did you get referencing for the
first one uh luckily i went to
i went to a landlord directly um and i
i had no reference to go through they
just let you off yeah
let me open but now you're finding that
it's all
yeah they're asking okay so what at this
week we get someone to come in as a
reference person
we get some money from packaging and
selling deals we get two or three more
rents events
we push your income up packages sell
some deals
we find a property that you can joint
venture with somebody on and become a
property owner
and then we find an apartment for you to
sign
and move to london
like literally i would do anything for
that so i honestly think we can make
that happen
let me go and get a piece of paper let
let's map out a plan
we need to be going right now map a
planet we need to be on right move
zoopla spare room linkedin
we need to be on craigslist gumtree open
rent
and getting as many views booked
tomorrow as we can to get rent to rent
deals
then we need to sell some deals drive
somewhere
package the deals sell them we should be
networking
we need to get a plan until it was hard
this week and i think it's possible let
me get a piece of paper
man i'm just featuring myself in that
apartment i can't believe that he said
that we can do that in a week
we've literally been up all night uh
going through
properties online strategizing a plan
i'm just super knacked but yeah peace
out for now guys
see you tomorrow we need to be getting
in
with management companies just tell me
what you're going to say when you call
them just
because this is your first time doing
this yeah i'll just say hi my name is
evansville
um i'm looking to uh you know get a few
rent rent in the area i realize that you
guys are
i wouldn't say that i wouldn't say i'm
looking to get a few entrants in the
area
i would just say and we give a
guaranteed rent to our landlords
and then the agents that we work with
just take their management fee
as normal but then we we manage the
tenants
um i don't know is that something that
you have done before or
correct yeah
that went well so basically he's totally
up for rent around yeah
he gets how it works and um
he's got a couple of properties that
could be good and what i would do with
the right contracts in place i'd rent it
out on a room by room basis
see my professional tenants i'm in a
position where i can take multiple of
you
if the numbers that are yeah hmos even
if i do three years or two years i
normally do a brick clause
reinhardt we got hunters we've got
multiple agents that are saying yes
we understand what you do rent to rent
we get it corporate let's
we'll pass you some stuff over we'll
pass you some houses over so as long as
we can make it stack
we've got those we've got deals just
walking into an estate agent they will
give you deals
what's the rent on this property so
she's currently asking 1600
yeah which as it stands 1600 is a good
though
because we can get 700 for room that's
uh that's going to be
2 800 pound 400 pound bills our cash
flow 800 pound but obviously
we have property investors we never
offer cash price so
okay so you reckon we could we can make
this one work
yeah as long as we can get over the line
hello
how are you doing okay no i don't want
to do that
sorry no problem at all you're scaring
me
hey i got the right property i think
you're with evans my friend
evans hi hello uh i'm evan's business
partner
would we be able to show our friend this
apartment
he scares you why does he scare you
he's very professional my tenant is
english yeah
10 years yeah very very good english
gentleman
very good our only trust in english
you only trust english people but you're
not english yourself yeah i only tried
my
my partner is english i only trust
english people
my wife is african i'm not trust but if
you don't trust anyone who isn't english
the the business owner is evans and
evans is from the caribbean
so if that's gonna mean that you can't
do business with him
then we can't do business because evans
is the company director
probably have to call it a day
sheesh so
she said that she won't do business
with us because you're the company
director and you're
not english these are the kind of things
i go through you know sometimes i'm glad
that you were there to witness it
i believe that you're interested in a
couple of our rental properties and you
guys are
subletters right uh yeah and then what
sort of um
clientele are you gonna get into
property what sort of profile of
applicant do you sort of usually
so it's gonna be you know young
professionals they are well vetted and
stuff
all right evans what i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna send you over a couple of pop
poppies across that are in healing i am
in the healing area so if i do like it
i'll get back to you shoppish
perfect you know all right thank you
muffy speak to you soon
great to meet you guys thanks for
letting us come
the around actually looks it looks
alright the location is obviously good
yeah now my thing is is the landlord is
he um
is he open to doing uh guaranteed rent
um
what guarantees renting it to a company
is it open to you to the concept could
be it could be as long as your
man there is a guarantor because this
was used as a renter and before wasn't
it yeah it was
okay cool they're not doing anything
i mean do i look like anybody was
anything illegal
you are okay with having a guaranteed
rent for on a corporate let
as long as you know that the money's
going to come in
yeah that's exactly what they want okay
so should we shall we make a deal why
don't we just work out what the funnel
off we can put forward is then
um and then and then let me know you
guys have to be right it's regardless
yeah shall we show them 76 or let's do
that i mean
do you want to see the other one yeah
yeah yeah yeah just do it yeah
700 times five why can't we just send
our final offer at the end of the day
even go around now if they're in hello
all right are you okay uh it's uh thank
you yeah um in regards to the property
yeah um is it possible i can go view it
now
oh yeah are you there now uh i'm
literally here now yeah
you're there now yes correct okay i'm
coming i'll see you soon
um well basically it'll be a company
left okay
so yeah this one's face
cool so this is the first double room
and it's got
three rooms upstairs and then a two
reception rooms downstairs
i really like this one samuel it's got
two bathrooms
um it's called you know it's very tidy
very clean
modern and for where it is
it's quite cheap they've advertised it
themselves
yeah so who's interested in having the
property it's it'll be our company
we wouldn't believe it
well that's um i mean what's it on for
one
one six why eighteen hundred eighteen
hundred yeah
ideally what is it that you really want
well yeah it would be good to give to a
company
okay yeah it would be good because then
you get you know it's guaranteed isn't
it
yeah yeah yeah than people just moving
out after a few months if we guaranteed
the rent
for say three years of a three month
break clause yeah what would be the
lowest you'd be able to accept and still
live with if we could guarantee the rent
so no late payments no management costs
that much 1800 1800 is what it's on for
obviously you wouldn't have to manage it
we would take care of
all that so you just get a
straightforward uh monthly rent okay you
didn't talk to mr singh
yeah okay yeah you've got his number
yeah yeah we have yeah yeah
we're gonna record in a bit then shall
we just work out the fine details but
thank you ever so much for coming over
atlantis
great thank you so much okay and have
you got any other properties or is that
the only one that you've got
there's a seven bedroom in west healing
is that available at the moment yeah you
want to see it yeah that'd be great
yes but we'll follow you down thank you
thanks jess
i think that one's gonna work always ask
the question what else have you got
i liked that i liked that well done i
think that's gonna work that
so four beds we'd rent each room out for
about 700
smaller one a bit less they want
eighteen hundred but oh i'm very
confident we're going to get
yeah hundred percent we just need two
thousand pounds a month in rental rents
two thousand pounds a month in deal
packaging that's your four grand that's
enough
for you to be able to rent your london
apartment
that's what i'm thinking this is my
lunch and breakfast
yes combined just a carpet yeah
how we basically make our money so with
this for instance this property
if we were to pay you a monthly rent we
would pay
the landlord a guaranteed rent and then
we then
manage it take on all the hassle and
responsibility and then we make a fee
you know obviously we make up um a
margin on it
yeah well we'll calculate it but of
course we need to make money on it
yeah um so we'll work out what we'd get
if it was completely full
yeah and then we'll put 10 down four
voids yeah ten percent down for
maintenance ten percent have a profit
yeah and then we'll then offer a
guaranteed event based on that basis
so we'll be getting a monthly a small
monthly profit yeah we'll have to factor
in costs
and hopefully we better take the
pressure off a little bit of the of the
tenant stuff
but real pleasure i hope we can do
business if the numbers can work
um as long as we're getting you know
profit from it
um and then from your perspective you
don't want the hassle so
we'll see if we can work out thank you
so much cheers
bye we're gonna get a deal with them 100
i'm
really really excited um it's recently
been refurbished it's an eight bedroom
already licensed for 15 people
how far is it how far away are we from
your house
about 10 minutes oh nice see that's the
thing there are deals
on your doorstep
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're not open to it that's no
problem at all just keep my number if
anything changes
nothing's going to change okay that's
fine thanks for your call anyway i
appreciate it
cheers bye stop him you know what's
happening though when you become like
more like i don't care
yeah it's a company that no there's not
a guarantor
but you know what here's what i can
offer you bang bang bang with confidence
because
you don't give a monkeys you why because
you're prepared to walk away
oh you don't accept company let's now
we're like we got too many company let's
take a hike bun we're good we're good
fool
like we got loads we've got too many
houses to view
we i i can't even cope with how many
estate agents and letting agents and
landlords are saying we want a company
that we want a company
so generally speaking do you think it's
better to email or to call
i think i think both in fact i think
everything i think you need to email i
think you need to phone
i think you just walk in to the shop i
think you need to go to viewings where
you haven't booked the viewing just not
the freaking door
i think what we're doing now is
everything everything
it's like when you go to war you don't
just go with one weapon you go with your
whole weaponry
so we need to go with everything which
is what we are doing which is why we're
going to get deal right now
and what what why does this something
say 20 minutes this one says 23 minutes
why do we even have two stat naps we're
using this one just turn this around
you might imagine what would happen if i
work as hard as this
every day you should man it's our
seventh feeling of the day do you know
the crazy things actually before i used
to work hard until today
are you coming or not yes um actually
what it is
we've obviously been stuck in in um in a
viewing um
also just be careful of using the word
obviously too much yeah
especially when it's not obvious what we
found is that letting agents find it
really difficult to rent out three bed
flats
because most people want a one bed or
maybe a two bed but if we can turn the
three bed flat and we can change one of
the reception rooms into our bedroom by
putting a bed in it and we can take into
a four bed flat
we can then rent the rooms out room room
room room
and turn it into a multi-let so as long
as we can get permission from the
landlord
as long as we can get permission from
the head lease if it's a leasehold
property
we can make really good monthly cash
flow by renting it for a cheap rent
because no one wants it
turning it into a multi-let and keeping
the profit in between
to be honest we're finding the three
beds are really hard
our company we've got we have an
overpopulation of people wanting to rent
out our yeah
our properties would would the landlord
looking for like a long term
yeah we've got bright claws in there
he's okay with that
cool and what do you think would there
be any
objections if we if we had um people
if we were people in the rooms like a
multi-let would that be
do you know if there's any restrictions
on the lease or anything to stop that
happening i don't think so no
i spoke to my manager about this morning
she said it should be fun should be okay
okay cool
i think this i think this one could work
it's a good really good location
so what i really like about three
bedroom flats is that you can turn the
fourth
living room reception room to a fourth
bed and the best thing about it is that
you don't need an hmo license
because if we can if we can rent these
for like 1750 a month
well then we can rent out the rooms for
750 each
750 550 that's 3 000 pounds that leaves
us with over a thousand pounds
we're going to pay the bills we've got a
little bit of bits and bobs we should be
able to easily make a minimum of 500
pounds profit
maybe even 700 pounds profit oh it looks
really nice though this this does yeah
tidy
that's good i do prefer this one even i
liked the last one but this one
which one are you more motivated to let
either anything at this time of year
with this one would it be the same story
with the landlord he'd be happy
for us to rent it out on multi as a
multiled and a corporate letter okay
cool
oh i like it yeah money in the bag
and again they've said they'll do
corporate let's say they're happy
so the world's alright well yeah i think
he wanted 1800
yeah i had another client you know yeah
uh
we were speaking down live 1800 yeah but
it's absolutely rough one where you can
do it
so i told you about you know you guys
won about three weeks went free
yeah you said you could start it from
the first of january okay
that's that gives you about two two
weeks something yeah
yeah okay i'll give you an application
now yeah
here we go
well let me get some money then we'll
shake hands
very nice done deal one
done although we now need to get the
money in the bank
yeah how are we going to get the money
how much you have in your bank right now
23 pounds 23 pounds and we need 3
200. we
[Laughter]
we need to uh we need a package and sell
some deals yeah
here's my suggestion we go home well we
go back to my house yeah
we um we go back to my house we need to
speak to some investors
yeah and we need to find out what
they're looking for find it
and then yeah yeah it's a plan demand
yeah 100.
we just got
is keeping the contract and he won't
give it to us until we paint 3200 pounds
yeah because guess what evan's got a
rent to rent
is that good news
i still can't believe that we actually
got a different agent the university the
same then go and sign the same they
actually never believe that you can
actually do that
with an agent get a deal directly and
it's not only one agent we've got
multiple agents
getting 3 200 pounds tomorrow out of
thin air
it's going to take some hard work my
fear
is that if we get loads more rent to
rents
like another four or five which we could
easily get from what we've done
but you need about four grand minimum if
you include the deposit upfront rent
maintenance refurb furniture probably
five grand
per rent to rent property that we get
yeah so if we certainly get five rental
rents we're gonna need
20 grand and we will get five rent
events
from the ones we got in the bag how are
we gonna get that money
well i mean today we've obviously
definitely proved
that we have no issues in getting rents
around yeah so if it means we have to
offload
you know one or two to bring in some
cash yep
we can easily use that cash to cover the
ones that we have
okay or i mean or
actually no i think that's a good idea
if we do that
you'll have two rent to rents you'll
have put no money
down at all because we'll have used
money that we've sold from the other
rent events
let's say each rental it's going to
cascade your 750
that's going to be 757 57.50
that's like over 2 000 pounds yeah maybe
2100. and on top of that
you've clearly seen that you can
package and sell deals if we manage to
get the money in
i don't think there's any reason why you
couldn't you you told me your end goal
was to live in a nice apartment in
london right now you're living in a
little
room yeah i don't think there's any
reason why you couldn't just do that
immediately
i think we almost should be looking for
properties for you apartments in london
that you can just move into what's the
end what's the end goal what do you
really want
what i really want is to be a homeowner
actually not just
rent a hmo but actually own hmo
to live in or as an investment as an
investment
okay so i definitely need to get out of
this illegal room we know that
with this kind of little room yeah um
that's done yeah
you are now out of your little room
that's done
you are not after this week you are not
going back to that little room
yeah i don't i don't think you'll
probably ever need to sleep in that
single bed again
hopefully not i honestly think that's
done so you want to be a homeowner why
don't we just
why don't we find you an apartment to
move into and find a house for you to
friggin buy
sounds like a dream to me what what
investment what kind of investment
property do you want and how are we
gonna i mean i'm thinking if we
if we can find a really good investment
property like this week yeah
we can find a joint venture partner to
come in on it
you be a homeowner you got your rent to
rent my name yeah
you've got your deal source and stuff
you got your flat
and you've got your homeowner thing i
mean geez this is a big week bro
so in terms of investment properties i
mean
what kind of where do you want to invest
if you had if you want if you were
financially free from rent to rent yeah
where are you going to put that and
you're making money from deal sourcing
on top and
you got excess cash flow and that's all
coming from london
where do you want to actually invest
liverpool 100
liverpool yeah okay why liverpool
because in liverpool i've done a little
bit of due diligence yeah
it's currently bottom out it is i agree
you know i checked on the deal saucer up
yeah but it's on its way up okay so what
what do you want to own
in liverpool what kind of so what i want
to do in liverpool is a hmo
okay so i believe to get a job you want
to own a hmo
in liverpool oh sorry go on yeah so i
believe to get a jv partner yeah the
deal has to be as sweet as possible so
possibly
a vr where you can pull out all of your
money yeah into a hmo
okay so in the meantime while we're
selling deals and stuff why don't we
just go to liverpool
find a brr hmo deal
get sweet deal i mean geez this is going
to be a crazy week if we pull this off
brother
when do you when do you think we should
go today i think we should go to the
ball tonight
who do you think is going to drive i
think because you look a bit knackered
i think i'll drive and if i get too
sleepy you take over but i'm good man
i'm psyched what time is it it's like
8 30 8 30. so we'll be in liverpool 8 30
in about four hours 9 10 about half past
12.
yeah and we can do the selling and we
can do the rent to rent stuff over the
phone
sounds like a plan to me is this the
videographer up for it
let's go all right man let's get to the
fog and get changed
cool let's do it good ready and go
fantastic cool i've just secured two
renter and deals
they're absolutely amazing cash flowing
a minimum of 500 pounds the amazing
thing about those two hmos
they wouldn't require a license um we've
already secured
no deposit three thousand pounds finders
fee
if you're interested drop me a dm right
now where are they they're located
in shepherd's bush w12 amazing area and
what's the monthly cash flow after all
expenses
monthly cash flow can go as high as a
thousand pounds consu
conservatively easily 500 pounds and
that's hmo without a license
how do people get in touch get in touch
drop me a dm
um unless let's do business
cool that's a great so i'll send that to
you
one hit one one hit wonder bro
to be honest i'm really shocked that
evans is even
keeping up with me not many people can
keep up with me
so we're off to liverpool i've packed
i don't know why i'm gelling my hair
just to drive to liverpool to sleep
but anyway we're going to go and try and
find a hmo which we can
put your money in pull your money out
find a joint venture investor
which evans is going to get 50 of the
money from it's ambitious
but he's literally within the space of
20 minutes
how many groups have you posted in seven
seven groups and what's happened i have
literally
exactly 18 minutes ago i have got
three inquiries one guy very interested
he says send him over the information
right now
on facebook on whatsapp groups i've got
two individuals let me just show you
have just sent to me right now
please could you send more information i
need to write a bullet point
brochure which is just like bang bang i
can write that for you if you want okay
we'll email it to them at the bottom of
the email we include a call to action
which says if you're interested in
securing it and you've got the money
text this number then text that number
goes through to you then you jump on the
phone to them
close the deal i'll type that email up
now okay send it and then while we're
driving anyone that sends you that kind
of thing
bang it out to them yeah and um we'll
you won't have any issues um you could
so easily get a fee out of all of them
yeah if you if you if you were like
right i need your money right now they'd
all pay
yeah the thing is what you're doing is
good because you're checking they can
afford it
you're checking that they understand how
the business model works all right cool
so what i'm going to do because
obviously now
now it's about 12 40. so let's talk
tomorrow at nine o'clock and then we'll
obviously have a plan to action
okay thank you thank you so much
absolutely no problem
thank you so much speak to you tomorrow
so it's like just after 8 a.m in the
morning
these are my running shoes in case we're
late for reviewing because i have to run
what i'm thinking is when we find an
agent how about this
i'll go in yeah i'll do all the talking
you listen
watch how it's done copy and paste then
moving forward that's right moving
forward
you do the talking use the template i
used
bang bang bang bang we're going to all
the different agents we can find in
liverpool
till we get a deal hi
yeah um we're just um looking to buy a
property
okay um it's only appointments
can we make an appointment yeah go with
me
all right thanks matt yeah one for sales
can't have anyone in branches covered in
all that
is that everything is that every agent
it's really annoying
like two four so they may be able to do
it but would just be the close branch up
here
so we're like hey we want a house and
they said oh you need to book an
appointment we said okay
let's book an appointment right now oh
no no no you can't do it you have to
phone to book an appointment
okay are there any other estate agents
around
he said yeah and whistle green what if i
own that estate agent right now
i'd be firing some people jeez
is this is this the place ah hold on
now this is the place it says come in
we're open good
hello so we're looking for an investment
property
yes we're from london but we've come
down for the day
kappa
so they've just given us the literally
given us the phone numbers of other
estate agents
they must have so many buyers and so
few houses all right let me let me call
these and see what
thank you for calling i'm gonna have
them now i'm gonna beat them
not answering the phone i've got a
feeling that they're just gonna
good morning how can i help you good
morning hi my name's samuel i'm looking
for an investment property
i'm in the area today i thought that the
old the old swan might be
the best place to go um to find some
potential
juicy investment deals yeah no i'll do
something
so i'm just covering the phone i'll get
my colleague to give you a call back and
he'll run
that would be amazing rather than
booking a sales appointment over the
phone i don't know if there'd be a
chance
i might be able to meet in person and
see what you've got
yeah that'd be great i mean if you just
tell me what time he's what did you say
his name was dave
um
that would be great yeah i'll come down
because it's raining and it's cold
and um yeah i'll come down i'll be there
in about i'll be there about 15 minutes
all right i spoke to you on the phone um
i got an appointment with david
yourself are you sourcing depends how
good it is the main thing we're looking
for is to buy run down properties
that we can turn into small hmos
like three four five dead hmos um
and then refinance them basically
what everybody's looking for the only
difference is
we buy quick and don't mess about in
other news
we've got a nova rental rent secured
from yesterday we don't need more
interest
but we've got no money yeah we've got no
money
okay so we're getting rent to rent from
yesterday still let me see let me see
let me see
where is that shepherd's bush yeah oh
oh this is on that one yeah isn't that
one oh
dude that that that that's a good that's
a good one so if we got we've got
four renter mint deals secured from
yesterday two with
natalie and then those two you're
getting yourself
so we just need to sell the two that we
got we natalie get the money in
use that money to pay for your two yeah
which is going to give you which will
mean you'll be making from rent to rent
two thousand pound a month
yep when we're going these properties by
the way it's quick yeah in and out 10
10 minutes 15 minutes max no small talk
no talking about the weather and the dog
i mean is it specifically hmos are you
looking forward to stuff like that yeah
hm has all
ones that we can convert into hmos
it's got a blue feature wall i mean
lower this house there's something about
this house
i don't think this is a gower
he doesn't need much money spent on it
it's already live sensor which means he
has grandfather rights
if yeah evans wants this house
he's upstairs negotiating man i want to
buy this house
come on i don't think so
evan evans yes
let's go man oh and potentially you
should want to do a deal
with it yeah let's go
i'm feeling really happy about this he
reckons he might accept 170 which is
which is a bargain not for this one the
third of december he accepted an offer
for 170
do you reckon do you reckon the buyers
disappeared because of some of the
things outside in the garden maybe
no the buyers disappear because we
should have never even listened to his
offer
sorry we've got to shoot we've got
another viewing but thanks for coming
out here we are back
i think we can get it though we're
talking the car i'm not trying to be
funny but why did you rush me out
at the house i used to be hmm before you
know that is
uh japanese not worried i think that was
in the house in the garden
in fact i don't think that was
pad was that in the garden i reckon that
house is worth nothing
did you see so did you actually see that
in there yes okay well i wasn't upstairs
i looked up still there
these are things you need to look for
man
he was so angry with me he was like once
you rush me up the house man i was i was
about to buy it i was that far off from
buying it i've got another view now
we do we'll drive next to you and you
just book some of you i'm actually there
today
uh i assume is today too soon for you
sir no
actually today would be great it's going
ahead at one o'clock so i can probably
get you in a
half one maybe all confirmed by half one
together
three four things already broke so this
is the property
all right this is one of you know 11 45
this is way better than right now the
app is yeah there's a lot of interest
because
i can't i can't see there being enough
profit in it for us
as developers it needs to like
financially make sense for us
what do you think would be the lowest
offer that you can accept and still be
able to live with so it was upon
offering you know roughly about 125 do
you think that's something that
you guys would accept how did you feel
that when
i mean i think we'd have to get up for a
minimum of 120.
yeah why don't we go to a hotel we're
not getting more viewings and
um trying to sell that meant to rent
there from yesterday because that needs
to go today we need we need we need the
money back from those two rent events
uh we obviously have to leave a preview
in all later so it's not going to be
today probably going to be tomorrow
but that's in the back you haven't got
anybody that's 100 city
okay all right all right
so they want the money now the rent to
rent wants the money
evans is trying to sell the rent to rent
deals right now walking around on the
phone
if she wants to at 50 no problem but she
has to
completely refurb the house so tomorrow
needs to be a big win
we've got two rent to rent but we need
the money to pay for them he's trying to
sell the deals now i might go and help
him in a minute doesn't make financial
sense
with you know upon one and two seven it
literally doesn't i'll tell you why
because it needs to be re-gutted like
the property's in really bad condition
it's a bit of a difficult day you know
samuel's
watch him he's taking selfies you're
saying that everything's okay but
we realistically got nothing in the bag
you know yes we secure two renters and
does what we haven't paid for them
because we meant to pay for them the two
dollars we got to sell but we've got no
money in the bank
send me those bank details over i'll get
that done within within the next
literally 120 seconds right and if you
could also send me that pack
or that email that would be really
helpful i'll call you back in 20 minutes
fantastic science group doing it right
now babe thank you speak to you
all right yeah actually
he's got half a million that is
awesome tick tick tick tell me the truth
now were you feeling bummed out earlier
i wasn't honest you weren't i was
honestly i wasn't okay
i wasn't man i brought i i'm an optimist
always
i always always see the good okay okay
[Laughter]
today's feeling a little bit better than
yesterday i actually sold the deal
i've got the money physically in the
bank um
samuel is saying that i go sell two more
and one minimum
your job get that sick get that to get
that three round of six grand
yeah and uh twenty we need to leave it
about ten minutes so i'm gonna quickly
get changed okay well the good job man
three thousand pound is not bad
yeah we need that to be six okay a
minimum
six feeling good yep
closing closing closing money money
money so based on what i've said to you
is there anything else that you need for
me to make a decision
uh well what i would like to meet up and
and
um
i know it's a little bit forward but i
don't know if we could take take the fee
off you up front
but have a contract in place that says
that if we
if we don't get a deal over the line
within the next 14 days
um we'll we'll then refund you and then
we can dedicate because we've had so
many people saying we want it we want it
we want it but it's just like
you know it's hard to distinguish who's
serious and who's not if that makes
sense
i completely understand sam uh samuel um
no that's perfectly fine at the end of
the day this is a business
all right evans if you ping over terms
and conditions as soon as you've
responded to the terms and conditions
and agreed well uh evans will send over
the invoice for two nine nine five
that's including your fees and
everything
and um and once we get the deal in the
bag as part of the service evans will
hold your hand
he'll walk you through everything help
you set it all up because it's your
first one and because we want to see you
succeed yes thank you very much
that'd be six thousand pounds in your
bank which means you can then pay for
your two rent to rent deals i've got
another one in the bag oh
good there's every nine thousand by the
time we finish the day
so my first deal was a lot harder
[Music]
now it's a lot more simpler now i've got
the contracts
i've now got the terms and conditions
the practical i know what to say i know
what questions to ask
i've actually so two days in the last
few hours i've got the third one pending
now i've got the knowledge and i know
how to do it here's the most amazing
things i never have to fill out a job
application ever again
knowledge is key this area feels rough
but there's a ranger
packed in there it's got all the windows
not broken
yeah that's probably someone like us
doing a viewing i think it's this one
these windows man you know i feel like
if i just like literally threw this down
on the floor it wouldn't matter that's
the sign the area is bad when you feel
like it wouldn't matter
by throwing junk on the floor
we'll only be like five minutes tops
another repossession
needs a lot of work i reckon it needs at
least twenty thousand
yeah this is a definitely needs a big
lot of work
so nasty room bit of damp
might even potentially be some
structural issues i'm not sure but it
does feel
a little bit that way too bad
problem is this is on for 55 000 we'd
spend 20 000 on it
and then the new value would be 75 000.
so we wouldn't be able to really add
value when you're doing a refurb every
time you spend a pound you want to be
adding three pounds
can't see it happening no so it's a big
fat
steamy smelly no how did the last
what did the last person think of this
they like it no
no i think i think i would agree with
them with a capital n
it's a no with a capital n but uh hey
thank you so much
have yourself a wonderful day good to
meet you
we've got lots on today you've got
something on your uh
yes
so is this is this a repossession on
this one yeah yeah yeah
it's nice it doesn't need that much work
does it
oh i think this is a good one
room big nice one ensuite
room room bathroom room
wc four rooms
95 grand in the area they're selling for
like 115.
around here it was previously bought 440
145 but then when we possessed
imagine when we buy and we can do it up
and get it looking nice it's gonna be
worth probably like 120.
what do you think of this as an investor
would you like to own this house
definitely it definitely doesn't need
much work it's in a very good area
you could do the work yourself
absolutely you could say to the
joint venture investors you could say
i'll do the refurb for free
you could pay for the refurb so you
could say need to refurbish every
position but i'll pay for the
you put the 95 grand in i'll pay for the
refurb
i'll find it i'll do everything i'll
manage it we'll go 50 50.
i'm still bad i reckon you could you
could do this all right okay we can
there's no not weed thank you so much
that is a good one so the house is in
the area
they're all selling for like about 115.
we get that for about 95 grand 96 grand
about 20 grand below market value
it does need a refurb but with evan's
refurb skills
from um the eviction i'm pretty
confident he could do the whole thing up
for like two or three grand
absolutely if we could rent that out as
a hmo that's that's a good
solid investment there um rented out
to the uh 30 to the first of july of
next year yeah
so it's ready for like nine and a half
grand a year or something yes
no yeah i need to call it ten thousand
pounds and it's actually rented out on
the first of july
of next year for another year wow it's
rented out to the 30th of june
2022 yep that's great i mean it's on for
110
are you are you going to hold out for
that are you open to negotiations at all
what we've done is we put it on on a
figure
that we think is a good figure for what
it is it's an investment
property it's somebody that doesn't have
to do anything so they can come in here
and they can say is it ready to go yes
it is ready to go have we got guarantors
in place yes we have
is that ever that everything is in situ
from day one
there's nothing that you need to spend
and you know that your income
is there to the first of
july 20 22.
nice to have an intelligent conversation
with a local investor that understands
the crack
why is it that we didn't offer we didn't
ask him what's the lowest again
he's willing to accept if we pay cash
because
i wanted to show him how awesome and
credible we are so that when we do put
our offer forward through the agent
he goes i like those guys they won't
mess around i need to accept our offer
okay i personally don't think we should
buy it but i think we should sell it
it's making 10 grand a year
gross yeah 110 000 he likes us a lot
you can add an extra room in time yeah
tenants in there until 2022 good return
i reckon we could sell that why'd you
wait why do you not think we should buy
it
to buy it we need to raise finance or
find the joint venture partner
which is hard and i think it although
it's good
i still prefer the one that we viewed
this morning his money's going to be
stuck in there isn't it his money's
going to be stuck in there
that's a good idea i want a brr for you
okay so up to three months and all the
contracts are included by you and you'll
work with them
and all the contracts are included by me
and i'm going to work with you as well
okay okay okay all right
yeah yeah fantastic you can set
you can send me over your term and
condition yeah
i will go through yeah through it yeah
yep cheers thank you
bye-bye good job i reckon he'll pay
he'll pay he'll pay yeah and he's got
100 grand in the bank
nice guy yeah we've got 4 000 pounds
already in the bank you've got 4 000 in
the bank right now yeah so then you need
to pay
pay for that rental rent now three
thousand two hundred you can pay it okay
cool
it's going well man it's a good day so
right now we've got one deal that he's
gonna do as a joint venture hopefully
fingers crossed a brr deal
we've sold a couple rent to rents got a
third venture we're probably going to
sell
we've find it found a really good hmo
that hmo i just want to get a hmm
management's opinion on it
so we're going to go to a hm management
shop talk to them about hmos pick their
brand see what's what
before we start packaging and selling
deals in liverpool especially if they're
hmos let's go
this is where we're probably different
to most hmo agencies we manage
19 major postcodes across the city
there's no one who manages hmos like we
do to the scale we do in the city
what are you thinking of the types of
deals that we're looking at uh
yeah solid i mean it's in it's in an
area where you've got options of
students and professionals so yeah
that's what i like about it
you know it's always good to have two
options so how many rooms how many rooms
do you manage in liverpool
just over 600 over 600 well hopefully
it will be 605 soon yeah thanks buddy
appreciate your time see you later
i'm proud of you brother are you ready
back to london
oh come on you haven't
you haven't nine thousand
nine thousand pounds in his bank
dude that's freaking good going yeah
that's freaking good going
okay so we've got nine thousand pounds
we've got two rents of rents have you
paid the dude for the rent events yeah
gonna pay him
no pay him pay him pay him pay for the
paying for the rent to rent
pay for the rent to rent number two yeah
so now
dude dude we're close we're close get
him paid
and then let's brainstorm okay that's
the one stamina evans is just showing me
his absolute dream
home apartment it does look good yeah
that's the one
if we can if we can get the keys to the
rent to rent we're gonna go and view it
yeah fantastic cool great
happy though that's all no
the reason why i agree to do business
with evans is because he seems very
trustworthy and i wish him all the best
in his future endeavors
oh fantastic well welcome boomshaka
[Applause]
now we need to find tenants the dream
room but before we do that we need to
find myself my dream
apartment that's true let's go let's go
all right that's the one that's the one
so we've got the keys evans is just
showing me his dream home
and we've got an appointment to go see
it yes what is
your dream home this is the dream man
this is more than a dream this is what
i've been
praying for big luxury apartment skyline
views if it's as good as that if it's as
good as that i'm excited
all right let's go view it cool
i really like this building you know
this is the nicest building here
you should just park my car and be meet
you in maximum two minutes
okay perfect that's fine hi good to meet
you hi
i know him oh you know me
good stuff man that's awesome what are
you guys doing here
well he's looking for an apartment to
move into all right perfect so
are you gonna join us yeah for sure
the living room we've got a different
view of the london actually the canal
and the city
and his face is quite happy with them he
loves it
he loves it evans would you like to live
here
oh man i'd love to live here have you
have you ever told uh
ellen i haven't even told ellen i
wouldn't tell her anything
he wants to he wants to surprise he
wants to surprise his uh his girlfriend
honestly he's got a really fantastic
view from here especially during the
night time
oh wow i can imagine what are you
thinking evans
i mean i can't even believe that it's
got the well designed isn't it yeah it
is it's a nice design
it's just the start i should show you
the other facilities that we have here
yeah no there's a gem and stuff here
isn't that we got jeans swimming pool
there's a 43rd floor skyline on this
building
that is absolutely breathtaking
dude i'll be moving out of my house man
are we coming down and joining you
i reckon you take this bro i reckon
especially as the agent is a fan
is a fan of my youtube channel yeah like
um what's that i just started my
business with you
what's ellen going to think of this
place
ellen will be absolutely crazy like
i'm praising myself and wow this is
great
this is more of a dream why don't we um
just secure it
and start the ball rolling i don't know
if we might be able to come back on
sunday to show your
yeah is it possible we're gonna come
back on sundays to to surprise my missus
i'm just literally leaving next door you
could just call me anytime i can't
comment
that's great fantastic so we're gonna
secure it today yeah
and then bring back ellen on sunday once
it's all yeah in the bag yeah yeah
we never met but i met you on the videos
right more than 100 times but we should
just keep that in mind
that if it wasn't because of samuel i
wasn't here to
write this flat so what do you mean i
mean if you weren't you i was still
working in the pub so wow
you changed my life and sent me to the
property section
and now here what i am so where am i now
it's just because of this samuel leets
the king i mean
it's absolutely because of him honestly
thank you so much for your videos
keep it on it's been good it's been
tough we'll fill you in
we'll see you on sunday at my house for
some for some lunch and
we'll fill you in on exactly what's
happened thank you so much see you on
sunday yeah
as i said i'd love to get my house or be
in one of my apartments in london but
i'll drop you a dress near the time
i'm so excited thank you all right see
you later
bye she has no idea
okay so we've just made an appointment
at my house or
at one of my apartments in london yep um
actually she's gonna be meeting evans in
your new
swanky london home what are we gonna do
i'm thinking
show around as if it's my partnership
but oh she's so nice and then you can
give her the keys and go
welcome home baby welcome home baby
we've also made out that the week has
been a bit crap yeah oh it's been
tough and she's oh i love you anyway
evans don't you worry
but actually it's been amazing
so i can't wait to see your face you
must be pumped to see your face i'm just
so excited
so i have to make a toast to evans
because today
he just picked up two rental rent deals
got the keys in the bag today mr evans
listen to this man literally this week
starting from scratch
he's packaged and sold a whole bunch of
deals he's made in cash in his bank
get it nine thousand pounds in a week
nine thousand pounds in a week
[Applause]
seriously from scratch that is that is
impressive from the 23 pound
23 quid from 23 pound to 9 000 yeah
thank you so now you've got 923
yeah for the 10. the 10.
yeah it's gold it's got a good ring to
it
he wants 10 000. he needs to sell one
more deal and then are we done
no no no no i think
i want to i want to be a homeowner oh
dude
so we need to we need to find a joint
venture deal for his one of his deals so
you've got a deal you've tomorrow
morning we're going to be on the phones
why tomorrow morning i reckon you should
call make some calls tonight
okay okay you can do it now i'm staying
in the top man
dude get the phone now do it now yeah
i've been like 10 minutes
no
man okay so we're gonna go make some
calls we're gonna go and try and get
some joint venture partners
evans is gonna get his ass dry we're
gonna go into the office
or in my bedroom we'll see make some
calls yeah boy
so in terms of the deal that you want to
sell to get your nine thousand
ten thousand i think you just need to
post on social media hit the phones talk
to people that you already know that's
easy the hard bit is going to be the
joint venture
who's the best person that's most likely
to join adventure with you i know we
spoke about
um a few people from the academy
potentially your girlfriend's
dad yeah i reckon you should just ring
your girlfriend's dad
like now good luck man good luck bro
don't need luck
now i'm gonna call my mom okay
so the reason why i'm calling is i'm
presenting you with a great opportunity
it's gonna be a win-win for all of us
i'll explain to you why in a minute
um so basically i'm thinking of actually
taking this property on board
so the main reason why i'm calling is to
pretty much just ask
if you would be open to being a joint
venture in this
in this property deal
so when you say joint venture what does
that actually
entail like fantastic so what he entails
is that the property needs funding
yeah so it needs funding um
it's a very very good deal obviously
some years frisking inside out
it needs about a hundred thousand pounds
up front
uh it needs a refurb which i am going to
cover the cost
and the you know overseeing that the
property will refinance
which means after the work is done for
about
right now for about a hundred and ten
hundred and fifteen
but it was it was sold a few years ago
for 145 so just by by buying the
property
you're already making money the good
thing about it is it's gonna generate
just over about a thousand pounds so
after the mortgage is paid it's gonna
bring in a few hundred a few hundred
pound
now when the property refinances you
will be able to get in about two or
three months you'll be able to take off
almost all of your money there's
probably gonna be about eight to ten
thousand pounds left in the property
um so and then and then obviously after
the property is yours so i know it's a
big ask i know it's last minute
if it's not worth the money that we
think it's worth we can just sell it
and you can pull out all of your money
so it's a very
um it's a very very good deal obviously
samuel is frisky and that's the main
reason why
i'm on the phone i want to phone to you
so so i'm not sure how you how you feel
about that
well it's it's not it's not what i was
expecting
in terms of like it's quite obviously a
substantial
investment requirement even if it's only
for the short
term so um i think i think what i would
probably
say is if you can
put some numbers down on paper
such that i can have a look at it and
just think about it a bit more and then
obviously
sarah and i need to talk about it as
well before coming to
any decision is that all right no that's
absolutely fine dad
i mean obviously it is a big ask the
only thing about this particular one is
that i would
i would need a decision uh in principle
uh by tomorrow
however i can obviously crunch up all
the numbers put in a nice email
send it over to you you can have a look
at it with her with mom
okay so that's great send send us over
to send us over the numbers and
because well because the other thing
you've got to appreciate here
is we would need a fairly sort of you
know
abc sort of janet and john sort of like
walk through
of what the process works thank you so
much dad i'll get over to you and we'll
speak uh we'll speak after
all right all right thank you dad bye
bye bye
what are you doing
he's just cautious put the numbers
together put it to him what do you
reckon
or not yeah probably maybe
maybe obviously you might want to see
the number one he needs to see numbers
yeah yeah that's how he is
he's he needs to look at numbers because
it's
it it's probably is there any other
people that will be interested in doing
a joint adventure on that
what about like john or i think it's
worth calling a couple of people now
just as a backup plan
he'll do it man i think he'll do it but
i don't know
i thought he'd let me sleep in his shed
[Laughter]
good morning everybody and welcome to
the
first ever virtual property investors
crash course
now please welcome to the stage my
friend my mentor
financially free financially magnet
property magnet in the world
mr samuel
[Music]
i know that this thing is quite
time-bound so
um uh sarah and i have been talking i
don't want to keep you in suspense
too too long um but so
just before we kick off where this is
heading um
i hope is going to be positive for you
okay
okay just so you know this is heading
because i don't want to like i don't you
think i'm stringing you along or
anything
well so what we're saying to you is um
yeah ah my [ __ ] battery died
hello i thought sorry the cold just uh
the coldest dropped because my battery
died
um but yeah i'm fully charged up and
ready to go don't worry
so i think what we're saying is um we'd
like
to um you know if we said to you
well we'd like you know we're happy to
go ahead with this
we'd like to um explore
you know a couple of options for how the
deal might actually work
yeah um but you know in principle
you know we're we're fine with it yeah
in some form we just need to work out
exactly how
would would that work for you right yeah
absolutely at 100 that's no problem at
all we can obviously always arranging
you know um you know how it can be
structured and whose name or is that
whatever we really appreciate it really
means a lot to me and this is gonna
springboard
um mine and ellen and even your um
you know property journey as well so it
really means a lot to me thank you so
much
that's fine so it's you know it's
exciting and you know obviously we're
we're pleased to to join in you know
basically yeah we're we're
we're happy jv partner baby i can't
believe it but that is crazy
wow man that's just sick man not only
have i found the deal from nothing
man this is crazy in a week
can you imagine what the future is going
to look like
oh wow did he agree yeah did you get it
on camera
yeah oh mate what's this one for
joint venture agreement
[Music]
so it was with his father wow all right
so now we need to just sell one deal
yeah
you try and work on that your best if
you can't i'll help you out towards the
end of the day
that's brilliant oh mate ah well done
man
good job bro how you feeling i've been
good you agreed
i just overnight 97 he's buying a cash
isn't he yeah
just off at 96 man what's up for 96.
get proof of funds over bang bang bang
bang making this happen now
that's phenomenal news i'm absolutely
stoked
that is just the icing on the cake so
what's happened is last week
um at the beginning of going you know
what it is i have to change that so when
i
took some massive massive massive action
um and literally today i can comfortably
honestly honor my heart say
i've made nine thousand pounds um in
packaging and selling deals in how long
in how long just this week just this
week nine thousand
pounds nine thousand pounds
and you've also another thing that's
happened is his deals are so good
that he's like man i don't even want to
sell these deals anymore
what happened just today evans uh what's
happened today is uh yesterday last
night i pitched an investor
a possible joint venture and he came
back to me for about an hour ago and
said uh yeah
he's happy to do a joint venture uh with
me who's putting in all the money
the investor all the money yeah and what
percentage are you getting the profits
50 50. 50 is putting in all of the money
why he knows how to find deals he knows
how to sell deals
what has been sleeping in a single bed
with his girlfriend in his girlfriend's
parents house
flat broke came to me with 23 pound in
his pocket
made nine thousand pound this week i'm
not done yet though i go get ten
thousand gotta get ten you get you'll
get ten
i'll help you later you'll get ten all
right give him a hand make some noise
for evans
make some noise
[Music]
is that your first stage
[Music]
how was it yeah it was um very good man
it's just like you know just reached
just saying what was happening just
crazy man i mean
i started the week like no money man i'm
on the stage with my mentor it's crazy
it's very emotional i mean i didn't plan
to cry i'm a big guy man it's very
embarrassing to see
people see me cry but you know just
saying it's very very emotional because
you know it's hard for you it's the
truth and i'm
i'm just forever grateful for what for
what simon has that for me um and for
what's to come
super excited have a safe trip yeah yeah
let's stay in touch man let's get in the
video man see you soon
take care mom nice to meet you nice to
meet you all right guys no worries
so basically did your joint venture deal
which is awesome you still need to sell
a deal
you need to make a thousand pounds yeah
what have you attempted to do
so i have attempted to uh sell the deal
for a thousand pounds the deal i've got
in liverpool yeah
um have you tried bespoke sourcing yet
yeah so basically his bespoke sausage
okay he's gonna spoke sourcing this it's
just like
hey i'll find you a deal what do you
want all right what do you want
oh you want that you want that kind of a
deal give me a thousand pounds
i'll go find it give me two weeks i'll
find that deal for you if i don't i'll
give you money back but he'll find it
why are you just going to try and sell
some of these guys have you spoke to
like sam's the dj guy
he got money there is he spoke to elliot
spencer he got money
these guys these guys have you spoke to
him
how come uh no idea
i haven't spoken to them because they
were obviously all busy go speak to them
man
that's ashley they're all investors now
we've got money
what about the people over here at sand
sands wants deals he does san just got
money to invade my friend
are you interested it depends what it is
that's what it is
what he wants is wow in fact let me get
hey have you got a minute no i'm telling
you
so basically uh obviously you know i'm
doing deal sourcing
[Music]
what did you see what anyway hey dude i
just got to turn this music off yeah
okay okay
so basically sanji's avoiding me oh he's
he avoided you yeah
yeah he said he doesn't want to hit me
all right we go you go try elliot
elliot's got money
he's got well more money than broke
assange all right
so basically i'm here to see if we can
obviously work out a transaction
okay i've heard that you you're in need
of a service i'm in another service so
maybe
we can come to a mutual agreement okay
so here that um
you know you in the market just put that
that's a mic we need to
we need to record this conversation
like i've just given him some credit
how's this
all right okay look i've got 20 i've got
20 grand
let's play with all right where you
after i'm after someone pull my money
out of
below market value and cheap i can get
bridging but i can get a mortgage
next year when my company's got two
years books
so if i was to find you exactly where
you
where you where you after would you be
willing to pay associate
for doing that yeah okay how much are
you willing to pay
so if so if i was to go out there and
find that are you willing to
you know right now do a bespoke source
away give
will you give me a grant i'll have 14
days to go out and find exactly where
you're after and if i don't i refund you
that
would you agree to do that so you've got
seven days 14 days
14 days 14 days to go and find me
something a brr
so something below market value yeah
absolute hell hole that can do up add
value to
pull my money out yeah um yeah and if
you don't
i'll refund you fives advance and if you
don't in 17
14 days ago okay yeah yeah deal
drop me invoice i'll give you my email
address tell me the t's and c's i'll
sign it i'll send you the grand over
sweet i'll get it over to you in the
next
half an hour awesome i don't care if
it's up north
north east north west obviously i don't
care where it is south wales
jaffe you happy you're the boss
why are you kind of yeah
so why wouldn't you want to do business
with my boy
because the deal's too small for me oh
the deal's too small
you wouldn't even speak to him bro you
wouldn't even speak to my boy
i've got you see you see people like
this these close-minded fools
you know he didn't know what he missed
samuel is my number one student
he's my number one that's what i love he
didn't know what he missed with his
implementer he didn't know what he
missed he know what he missed
god bless you brother here's the thing
with evans okay evans was trying to sell
a deal
to people on facebook but there was
people around him
investors millionaires that would have
done the deal
to the very end of the evening i was
like have you ever spoken to sand you've
spoken to elliot spoken to this person
who spoke to that person he's like
no but and that's here's the lesson okay
sometimes it's right under your nose
his stepdad or his girlfriend's father
right
joint venture right under his nose randy
knows there's a lesson in that why did
you not speak to your
girlfriend's father sooner what did it
take this week you could have spoke to
him last year
that's very true um i honestly
you know didn't believe that i i know
that you trust me um
but i didn't think that you respect me
as a property yeah
investor so you didn't have the skills
yeah you didn't have the knowledge you
didn't have the skills then as soon as
you get the skills
people start taking you seriously when
you start having the deals people start
taking you seriously absolutely because
the skills produce the results and the
results speaks volumes exactly man well
you did it
i did it i think we need to now we need
to go to bed
and then tomorrow morning go to your
apartment get the keys
and surprise your good lady
[Applause]
below market value some achieve um
something i can hopefully pull my money
out of add value
and um and yeah just recycle my cash
hopefully
yeah if you're good if you can pulls it
off i'm looking to be i am actually
talking about that i know that's really
cool she's a really nice guy
really nice guy yeah i'm excited
really excited you did it
yeah i did
i still believe i'm dreaming i feel like
i'm dreaming
i can't believe that literally in one
week with you
well you've done 100 000 pound joint
venture
yeah you've made 10 grand now you did it
you've got two rent to rent deals you've
got the keys dude technically right now
you're financially free bro
i am i literally am in
one week with you what would i do
without you
i'm proud of you bro honestly i don't i
really don't think
i could have envisioned it any better
yeah work so freaking hard i can't do it
and i think you deserve every every
single bit of success
you know yeah oh my goodness
christmas is coming
[Laughter]
so this week i've made far too much
money
and um samuel challenged me to give 10
of my earnings to charity and you know
what
challenge accepted so what i'm going to
do tomorrow
i'm going to give 10 which is a thousand
pounds
to the homeless in the streets of london
i'm really excited about that and but
most importantly
the look on ellen's face when she sees
our new home our amazing apartment in
the center of london
i'm also going to send ellen
um parents away for a week um they've
really helped me out and you know what
it is
i really want to give back to them
because it really helped me i can never
forget
i can never forget last year christmas
um
you know it was you know it was so bad
that i couldn't i couldn't even um
you know i couldn't even i couldn't even
buy gifts for anybody i couldn't buy
gifts to my son
but this christmas will be far far
better um so i just really want to you
know contribute and support
your foundation by giving you a thousand
pounds of
what we've obviously made this this week
and hopefully it's going to be the
beginning of
what's to come i can now start thinking
sleeping bags for the homeless i can
start thinking
about hats and scarves even socks for
the homeless
you know gloves and it doesn't sound
much but you start adding that up it
comes to a lot of money and it wasn't in
our budget
so i really do thank you for that it's
absolutely phenomenal so as well as we
spoke on the phone
he's gonna give a thousand i'm gonna
match that as well so it's gonna be two
000 to help the homeless in london this
christmas benefactors turn up as i
always say
benefactors will come bless you and
thank you thank you both of you
[Laughter]
man making money is great but there's no
greater feeling like giving back
to charity there's no greater feeling
like giving back to you
to the less fortunate we're just pulling
up so when you get there
uh give me a call i'll come down and
we'll let you in
all right do you think that she suspects
anything at all no there's no way
there's no way she'd believe that i put
i pulled this out of the bag in a week
like no way she didn't know what she
should ever have anything so when she
gets to the apartment
we're just gonna say it's my apartment
we're wanting to have a debrief with you
come on up she'll come up you don't
think she'll suspect
and then when she gets up go up to the
apartment and then
i'll let you do your thing and tell them
what's what yeah
sounds good oh mate i can't love it i
can't wait to see your face
what's up my friend hello gents are you
good
working around cool this is
this is sick man i can't believe i'm
gonna be living here bro this is sick
look at that
because i've told her this is my
apartment and i want to have a meeting
with her
okay so so she's going to so she's going
to come up
and she'll think it's mine but then when
she gets there
show me evans and evans will say this is
our new home baby
get ready to move in all right this
morning personally came here i literally
cleaned
every single chat
you can go get her away in the apartment
she's got no idea what she's about to
see
baby this is crazy
there she is hello princess
[Music]
let's go this week was hot in it i think
i missed you more this week
come listen they've been asking me so
many questions like how's everything
going yeah
i'm glad that your dad agreed so this is
he's gonna do he's gonna show you that
he's gonna show it around
okay i know have a quick difference
[Applause]
welcome to my apartment thanks wow this
is some beer
i know it's great grab see so
it's been a good week so we thought we'd
give you a little bit of an update
he's made some good money now you'll be
really pleased yeah so i think this is
what
all right you got the view in here as
well he's making some sick money here
you can see everything yeah and uh
i think that's the bigger room it's the
two best service service accommodation
look at that i got the views man level
you can pretty much don't have done we
always said we wanted someone with a
view
yeah i'll get it one day i'll get it on
the inshallah
okay so let's go on tweet this one yeah
so yeah that's pretty much it
and i'm gonna let you guess how much i
make on the apartment in a minute
oh gosh that's gonna be so hard to get
well this apartment actually
um well guess how much i make on it a
month i can't guess i
i don't know a month so do you do a
service accommodation
or this property i'll tell you exactly
how much i make on this property
i make nothing on this house and the
reason i make
because this is our house this is where
we're gonna be staying
this is our [ __ ] man what do you mean i
just want to thank you for everything
you're gonna make me cry um you've
helped me from like
from the bottom i just want to let you
know that you know i got you for life
so we've secured this this is our home
[Music]
i love you so much and i love this
apartment it's
so perfect are you serious for real
serious honda
what do you mean this is our apartment
what do you mean
and we have a just so you know we have a
gym downstairs we have a sauna
we have a pool and we have a jacuzzi and
we have a sky lounge upstairs viewing
the entire of london
and this is exactly what we said we
wanted it was exactly like the plan
everything and in one week i told samuel
and he made it happen so it's not me
samuel
[Music]
i don't know what to say i never ever
would have guessed this
no way ever would i guess this
i feel like i thought he would do well
but like was not like this
why don't you look around again with
fresh eyes knowing that this is your
apartment
grab a look have a look again
[Laughter]
our double bed for the first time we
haven't got to sleep in a single bed
ever again
and we have a bedside table normally we
use like the laundry bag
[Laughter]
i mean i'm not here at all i'm like on
the skies at the moment so happy that i
see samuel
i mean he was a hero for me from the
beginning just take this one yeah he was
my hero
all right it was really lovely to see
i'm gonna go wait in the car now let
these lovebirds do their thing
my job is done
[Music]
is it too good
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
oh my goodness no matter what do you
think of the apartment
i absolutely love it it's just beautiful
the view i'm you know the view is just
could
could you live here yeah i i could
literally see it
outside of the this fabulous apartment
like on the property side obviously we
did a lot of deals
yeah how have things been since what
have you done since
we finished the challenge a couple weeks
ago yeah well today actually
i quit my job oh my goodness
and she can do that comfortably because
as you've seen the restaurants are going
very nicely looking over two thousand
pounds
of the calendar month yeah you made over
sixteen thousand pounds
in packages and the pro
deal is going on very nicely and on top
uh we've got a huge development in the
pipeline so honestly saying believe
me when i said it this week i've been
with you has dramatically changed my
life for i'm so grateful
it's like the most incredible outcome
in the short amount of time absolutely
to
financial freedom oh yes well done
do you think oh my gosh i knew that he
was gonna become financially free
because obviously he's spending the week
with you
okay but the extent of how successful
he's actually like made it and like
where he's living how much money he's
made is insane i know i'm impressed it's
incredible
i'm impressed you know what he deserves
everything he's got that guy he's a good
guy he's got a good woman
so i'm over the moon i'm over the moon
it feels like a lifetime ago just crazy
to think
three weeks ago we couldn't even like
sam couldn't even stay on our floor
and now we've got this gorgeous central
london apartment we've got a spare room
for samuel to stay
so much has happened in that short time
i mean i've left now left my job
thanks to you yeah now you know it's
actually it hasn't been easy to be
honest
in fact the week was probably one of the
most hardest weeks
but at the same time one of the best
weeks i've ever had uh we signed up with
racism
and tons and tons of rejection uh but we
kept on going and um
and now i mean now we're financially
free
[Music]
stuck in the pools